all right you know what this means are
you thinking what I'm thinking that's
right
live-action tailspin movie I mean why
not the same cast to just do another
thing so bring on the scenic serious the
Jungle Book so the jungle book is
Disney's live-action telling of the
story of the jungle book done by I
believe it's Disney live-action Studio
Department that ultimately they're
tasked with taking the Disney
Animation's and turning them into
live-action versions of themselves so
setting it up Mowgli is the man-cub he
was a little child found by a panther
named Bagheera voiced by Ben Kingsley he
was brought to this pack of wolves they
raised him as their own and all the
animals in this movie talk just like
they did in the Disney Animation and
there's this truce going on right now so
the circle of life has ground to a halt
no one's gonna kill anybody and Shere
Khan steps onto the scene he's like once
this truce ends that thing is dead yeah
we'll talk about Shere Khan a little
later but for right now all he knows he
wants Mowgli dead so now Bagheera is
like I need to take Mowgli and take him
to the human village because that's
where he needs to be so it's an escort
mission man taken from point A to point
B and then trials happen along the way
right getting right into it this movie
is pretty friggin sweet I'm not just
saying that it was an exciting movie I
really liked how visually it's appealing
as hell you completely forget not only
are all the animals CGI but the scenery
in the forest that's all not real - I
was gonna say it's fake but that just
doesn't injustice and in that the kid in
this movie was really good he was good
as far as kids go and then you remember
like this kid is CG eyeing this entire
thing he is looking at nothing and
acting I've seen adults fall flat on
their face with that constant this kid
is really killing it can't wait to see
more from them and I love the
relationship between Mowgli Bagheera and
Baloo because really it's the odd couple
with a kid Baloo voiced by Bill Murray
and this is the best I've seen Bill
Murray be in many many years I feel like
he's been phoning it in lately this one
I was like this he is cracking jokes man
there's there's some snappy dialogue in
this movie and Baloo Bill Murray
does a lot of it in Bill Murray fashion
the Bill Murray you knew in love and now
know and
present tense because a balloon but
really balloons like the dad who just
wants to play and have fun all the time
so Bagheera has to be mom voice has to
be like no I am order and we're doing it
this way does the mom look all hands on
the hips like that's my that's my mom
right there it scared me this movie was
exciting there is one Stampede scene I
was like that's Lion King I'm just
saying just saying all that tells me is
they now need to do a live-action Lion
King and call it Hamlet but you see
elements in this movie that you're like
all the totally harkens back to the
animation I remember that something's
jog your memory I was like oh yeah the
King Louise scene that was my favorite
scene in the animations one of my
favorite scenes in this movie too once I
recognized the voice man I was like that
is Christopher Walken is King Louie
amazing give me the fire everyone loves
a great villain man so we're gonna talk
about Shere Khan for a second Idris Elba
voices Shere Khan and there's duties
businessman he really wants this kid
dead right out the gate that's gonna
freak kids out so he wants to kill
something like me dude he has such a
great introduction I love a great
villain with a great introduction and
conviction and he has all of that great
presents - man Shere Khan
every time sure Kong is on screen it's
tunnel vision you're like Shere Khan and
nothing else and he does some things in
this movie where you're like whoa and I
thought to myself like all right well
that's what they get because it's a
pg-13 movie
oh no it's rated PG you should call this
may be guaranteed bed wetting because if
you take a kid young and after this
movie that's exactly what you're gonna
get parents there is a part where a song
starts one of the songs is really
organic the way they're doing it cuz
like it's like it's bare necessities and
Baloo and Mowgli are just kind of going
back and forth you're like all right I
kind of get it's not it hasn't hit
musical tone yet they're just kind of
bantering back and forth with him other
than that there's none of the jungle
books songs in this movie until there is
one where straight-up goes into musical
mode and I was like that's kind of
jarring the last song wasn't like that
this is one of the two songs in the
entire movie that people are singing or
animals are singing I call them people
because they are and it kind of didn't
fit in the movie but yeah again you're
like you can't help it the nostalgia way
if you feel like cause right in front of
your eyes Robin you're like mr. G yeah
okay and in the movie is a simple
premise really take the kid to safety
but it's done in a way that's
interesting yet accessible for all ages
old enough on that's in the end the
Jungle Book was what I was
hoping for great lead actor up against a
green screen the entire time great voice
acting great chemistry within the
characters this is one of the better
movies this year and for right now I'm
going to say the jungle book is
certainly worth buying on blu-ray I
might bump it up we'll see how the top
ten of the Year list goes I don't know
yet right now I can only really
recommend the jungle book cuz it was
excellent alright guys so the jungle
book have you seen it what did you think
about it what's the next Disney
animation you would like to see turning
to live-action be it CGI or otherwise
whatever it is wherever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more